I was fascinated by your process you're
laying in a pool perhaps where you're
most relaxed yeah and you're daydreaming
yeah
and you see you say the opening scene
to the movie yeah and that's why you've
said my opening scenes are always my
best because that's what gets me going
if I see a great opening scene in my
mind yeah
then I know I'm on to something Django
is a good example but because I was
doing press for uh Inglorious Bastards
in Japan
and I was hipped to that there was this
uh
magnificent store in Tokyo that sold uh
uh uh soundtracks they had a lot of
great spaghetti western soundtracks so I
went down to this store and it was all
DVD all CDs and man they had spaghetti
western soundtracks that you just
couldn't get in America I couldn't
believe it and so I mean I I just and
they had record I mean I just bought so
much I just looked like a rich [ __ ]
all right but what a weird little store
huh yeah like but like jam-packed too
you know yeah and so like a stack of
Records this big and two bags of of CDs
and so I get back to my hotel room and
I've had like a day off I did it on my
day off
and I'm just just luxuriating and all
this like morocconi Louise bakalov
spaghetti western music and it's just so
great or whatever and I've been having
the idea for for Django for a while and
then all of a sudden it's like after
listening to this stuff like for hours
I kind of sat down and uh I didn't even
have my notebook with me which I
normally have like a writing notebook
with me so I just took the stationery
from the hotel room does that drive you
crazy that you don't have your writing
book with you why wouldn't you bring
your writing book with you I don't know
I I always have it with me I what is the
writing book is it a special kind of
paper no no it's just a mead Mead
notebook you know a little ring binder
notebook you know so I had the pen
that's on the little desk in the room
and then I had the stationary from the
uh uh from the hotel and then I sat down
and then out came that opening scene in
Django where you know the the slaves are
being led uh on the Chain Gang and then
Dr Schultz with his wagon with the tooth
going back and forth comes riding up and
then they had the whole encounter and
then I wrote the scene and it's pretty
much
what's in the movie and when I finish I
go okay I guess this is what I'm doing
now could you make Django Unchained
today I don't even think you could yeah
I could you think you could if I wrote
Django and chain it's not like all the
students gonna say no
I don't know the political correctness
now yeah
so we had bad think pieces but bad think
pieces are actually good
that means your movie's about something
that means you're that means that
they're having a conversation about your
movie that means that you're part of the
Zeitgeist now you have to have the balls
and the shoulders all right to handle
those bad thing pieces and there's
usually good reviews that go along with
it and now when it's over and no one
remembers those [ __ ] pieces but they
remember the conversation
foreign